[Applause]
so okay so just to introduce well not
only myself but maybe also the alan
turing institute which is the which is
one of the two institutions I'm
affiliated with you may or may not be
familiar with it is the UK's National
Institute for data science and ei I
found that a couple of years ago with
the aim to catalyze the research
application translation and innovation
cycle so the two Institute does
foundational research it aims at
applying this directly to solving real
world problems it also provides training
to the next generation of leaders in the
area and it's also meant to advise
policy makers and shape the public
discourse now if you are a member of one
of the 13 partner universities you can
become a fellow by applying one of the
regular calls but the Institute also has
its own staff the fellow is our fellow
Spicer compliment but the Institute is
regularly hiring staff at all seniority
levels it has its own growing research
engineering group and a cohort of PhD
students as well as research assistants
at PhD and postdoc level so there's
applications open on which you can look
at the touring website there is events
happening you can get involved for
example in data study groups where
companies present events and you can
apply to participate and work on a
one-week intensive event to scope
approaches data scientific approaches
you can also get involved with one of
the numerous tools projects that happen
in the recently started so it's quite
quite new end of last year the tools
practices and systems theme that is now
ramping up at the touring and which
we'll be hiring soon and remember we
have taps from which coffee flows at the
Institute that is not that is not a joke
back to my talk so this is about the SK
pro package which sits in the socket
learn and PI data ecosystem what I'm
going to talk about is the package
itself which is a tool but also it is as
much a package as it is a vision of
things it can do or should eventually do
so this talk is split in two parts first
explaining what is probabilistic
supervised learning so predicting with
an uncertainty estimate of the
prediction itself as well as
highlighting in which respect SK Pro can
or cannot yet do that so contributors
Fritjof Grossman who is the main
developer of SK pro couldn't be here
today he was originally supposed to to
give the well presentation of the the
repeater notebook presentation but he's
been now hired by a large ml AI hardware
company so he couldn't be here because
he needs to go to I CML and I believe he
needs to check whether there's anything
interesting happening so it will be just
me giving this talk but free to of is
really the main developer behind behind
the packet itself and we're currently
looking for a new developer because his
professional endeavors don't allow him
that much more in terms of further
developing the package so there might be
some hiring arounds upcoming as well so
references there's a long paper on the
vision probabilistic supervised learning
which has appeared as an archive
preprint and the cylinder reviews it has
appeared last year I've pushed a new
version with some typos fixed and there
is one short paper that is exclusively
about the package escape row which has
appeared in the M lost so the machine
learning open source of the workshop and
Europe's last year okay what is this
about what so first part what is the
general vision of probabilistic
supervised learning if you recall
supervised learning
those of your family Larry psychic learn
all right so you have a learning machine
which in psychic turn is an abstract
estimator class that ingests training
data feature labeled pair so for example
multiple pieces of information if it's
yellow and round it's a lemon so yellow
round lemon yellow and round being the
features or it's yellow and not wrong
it's maybe a banana so yellow banana so
this is in the training face the
learning machine constructs a
representation of the reality as
observed through these features in
labels as a fitted model and later on it
uses that to make predictions when you
have only features so for example if it
is yellow and if it is round what is it
it's maybe it's maybe lemon then you
have all these kinds of tuning
parameters and the interface circuits
are improvised for that but there is a
lot of examples in the machine learning
zoo of supervised learning which is the
bread and butter for many machine
learners to come up with new methods or
improvements upon methods or proving
something about these methods now what
this talk is going to be about is the
predictions with uncertainty or
probability of probability estimates so
one way you can call supervised learners
is making a point prediction which is
essentially the learning machine tells
you oh I'm certain this is an apple
because it's round and it's not yellow
or you can make a probabilistic
prediction say I'm 25 25% of cases this
is probably a banana but in 75 percent
of kids in the long term
it's going to be an apple if you're
familiar with scikit-learn and you will
recognize that this maps directly on to
interface points key interface points
the predict method and the predict probe
our method from the scikit-learn
package so what we're going to talk
about is predict proper like things so
obtaining this kind of prediction is not
only in a classification but in a
regression sense which SK pro means to
address so more generally and you might
be familiar for classification which is
maybe the most frequently used case and
practice so I
learn more discover this already with
the predict proba interface so but just
to explain what do these probabilities
mean they there are frequencies
probabilities if you invoke predict
proba for the models that scikit-learn
implements they will be frequent these
probabilities meaning if you have these
features out of 100 independent cases
say 25 are going to be bananas 30 are
going to be apples 45 are going to be
frogs or whatever whatever kind of
classes you want to put them into so
this is different from the Bayesian
belief probabilities primarily we'll be
talking about the frequency
probabilities so in long term if you
have these features what are you
expecting to observe now for regression
let's say you want to predict the number
right so want to predict a patient's
individual survival in terms of in terms
of years given demographics given given
a therapy they have received so what is
that number or say you want to do one of
the things that the hosts and sponsors
of this event like to do there it might
also be useful so one way to do this is
to produce predictive intervals which
say for example in 95% of the cases of
long term the observation will be
between these two numbers or you can go
fully probabilistic right so you can
specify a full distribution over numbers
over the reals so say in long term it's
going to be as if it were sampled from a
Laplace distribution with certain
parameters for example or normal or
whatever whatever you want to predict so
that is essentially what SK Pro is meant
to cover especially the regression
aspects which currently it's a little
bit difficult to get out of out of
scikit-learn or related packages so in
terms of in terms of the toolbox the
features that it currently has or in the
long term is meant to have
[Music]
exhaustively one is the creature that
you know from scikit-learn a unified
interface for probabilistic supervised
learning methods so that means it needs
to have a predict method that returns
these kinds of probability predictions
that you have seen in the in the last
slide furthermore support for the model
building and model evaluation workflows
that you know and love as well from
scikit-learn
that includes the possibility to build
pipelines to have three processors to
plug together building blocks like
transformers or feature extractors with
more a model interface to have
compositors say ensemble and meter
learning as well as automated tuning of
model parameters which to interface also
supposed to expose all four models that
output these probabilistic predictions
in the regression case as well as model
checking model evaluation if a model
produces a prediction interval well is
it good or is it or is it bad so
especially with a feature being well
frequentist models can do with this
Bayesian models can do with this you can
also couple together modulus in a
different way that produce predictive
intervals for distributions and you want
to assess all of them fairly with
respect to their predictive performance
as you are doing same scikit-learn based
cross validation experiments as said
some of these features are more mature
than others and we're looking for a new
main de Voort these contributors now
what are concrete strategies that do
that what are concrete types of models
so probabilistic supervised
classification essentially anything that
has predict probing scikit-learn or
neural networks with a vanilla softmax
output they also give you probabilities
if you if you don't threshold but let's
talk about regression say predictive
intervals the green is what is in some
way in some way you can do it with SK
Pro at the moment
it might be more of this buggy depending
on what the method is so SK learned some
of the some of the methods give you back
and mean and the variance so you can use
of course these two to get back some
predictive interval by using normal
approximation for confidence intervals
and also the two-step prediction as a
relatively classical method I think from
the 50s
one method predicts the mean by saying
the squared loss then you take the
residuals of that squared them and break
the squared residuals and then use that
as a variance or a scale component or
simply as if Y is the width of a
predictive interval quantile regression
models you might have seen them if you
use the quantile also the pinball was
right you and if maybe you want to
regularize but this gives you models
that predict quantiles you can predict
say ninety seven point five percent
quantile and the 2.5 percent point of
the predictive distribution so you need
at least two of these or you need a
joint model then you also get predictive
intervals so if you want full
distributions well if you have a fully
specified probabilistic model fit by
maximum likelihood of penalized maximum
likelihood such as the black hole model
adapt that will give you a probabilistic
prediction there are couple of models
that do so conditional density
estimation is not Araya Watson style
nonparametric density predictions it can
also turn prediction intervals into a
fully probabilistic prediction you take
the width of the interval and you put a
distribution you slap a distribution on
it which has a male and may mean and the
scale parameter patients rejoice you can
take page and predictive posteriors but
there are a number of caveats which I
don't have time to talk about today is
not every predictive posterior is
actually a predictive distribution with
good frequencies properties it depends
on whether you predict the full
distribution or whether it's just a
belief distribution for a point
prediction if you don't know what this
is don't vary ask the Bayesian and you
can do empirical risk minimization with
respect to losses that measure the
goodness of models that are
probabilistic which I'm going to talk
about in the moment so you could for
example set up and your network which in
its output layer gives you a
distribution and you could optimize for
that and see what happens now I said we
need a main depth we need contributors
there might be options to do this as a
as an actual internship job and so on so
like I know if you're interested in that
know I've already mentioned this at the
end so what is a what is a good
probabilistic supervised learning so
let's say you have one of these methods
you have a full zoo of methods and many
more than there was mentioned in the
last slide which spits out a prediction
interval or a flow distributional
prediction but is that a reasonable
thing that it returns right so what what
are things to consider there is a
frequent mistake and I just want to say
this slowly and clearly it is a mistake
to believe just because an algorithm
returns a prediction that is
distributional that is a statement about
how uncertain the algorithm is just
because an algorithm returns that it
doesn't mean that is correct now the
algorithm doesn't need to be right so a
predictive interval may be wrong just as
a point prediction can be wrong a
distributional prediction can be wrong
just as a point prediction can be wrong
because all models are wrong but some
are playing stupid and some are
reasonable to use so just to reiterate
this just because just because an
algorithm makes a probabilistic
prediction just because it states how
uncertain it is does it mean doesn't
mean it is always correct now of course
it isn't
hence it is important to distinguish and
it might be worthwhile to keep in mind
keep this in mind in what follows to
distinguish what the algorithm says
right so a predictive interval might be
I'm relatively sure the value will be in
there
but the algorithm can be wrong so there
will be a performance the algorithm will
have a certain performance in making
that kind of prediction for example the
statement will look like on average oh I
didn't train test plate it has a certain
loss maybe the cross entropy loss of 0.4
now in another layer that statement in
itself is uncertain because it is
obtained from a finite amount of data in
all practical settings so you might be
only certain about where this
performance lies say in terms of a
frequentist confidence intervals that
you compute frequentist asymptotics of
algorithmic performance on the test set
and you will get this if you if you do
this thing in a clean way now of course
this is different from the prediction
itself it is a statistical statement
about the performance of an algorithm
that itself may make statements about
how uncertain it is there's multiple
layers here but it's important to
distinguish what is the uncertainty the
algorithm claims what is the observed
performance of the algorithm in claiming
that uncertainty
what is the experimenters uncertainty on
the algorithm spec about the algorithms
performance so it's easy to get this
confused but in my opinion this is
important because it makes a difference
if you mix it up or not between an
algorithm that works or an algorithm
that doesn't work for whatever purpose
you want to apply if it's survival
predictions if it informs medical
decision making you want to be really
sure right you do not want to you do not
want to get a therapy recommendation
from an algorithm most creators have
believed that it is always right while
it isn't so how do you measure how do
you measure the goodness of an algorithm
that makes probabilistic predictions so
by probabilistic losses obviously which
which is theory that is mostly classical
though it is usually not praise its
losses it is still not
thing I have invented why a
probabilistic loss is useful they useful
in two main use cases one is fitting the
model if you specify say a neural
network you're minimizing and also if
you specify you're specifying a model
then say you want to do regular eyes
empirical loss or some some likelihood
based method then you're already using
something about how well the model oh
well the models are outputs with the
data second just evaluating it but how
good is the model how good is the model
that you have observed making
predictions in both cases you need to
compare observations that are saying
real numbers with predictions that are
distributions of prediction intervals so
on the test set you will say have a
thousand observations which are numbers
and a thousand predictions which are
individual predictions of distributions
so the loss function needs to compare
pears with apples an observation that is
a number with the distribution that is a
distribution over numbers or an interval
so unlike in the classical setting you
will have lost functions where the two
arguments are not exchangeable in terms
of type and these models are not going
to be symmetric either but now what is
what is a reasonable thing to postulate
so this is maybe the only piece of
deeper maybe not not that deep depending
on what your background is martyred I'm
going to show well it may be important
to understand so the intuition is
postulating that making the correct
prediction minimizes loss in the
long-term average so in expectation
mathematically expectation over the data
generating process a label generating
process here which is wine so you have
to think of it why this is also telling
you that in the conditional case of
conditional on features it's the right
thing to do
but I think it's a very reasonable thing
to postulate it making the perfect
prediction is going to minimize the loss
on average
now if this doesn't tell you whether
such a thing exists but the alternatives
are as something else minimizes it so if
you optimize for it the prediction might
be optimizing a criterion it doesn't
have to do anything with the truth
anything with the tool distribution but
you want the true or generative
distribution for the prediction which
which i think is quite a sensible thing
so one terminological issues you may
have heard the term proper scoring rule
that's just with the sign flipped but
I'm talking about losses because I think
being familiar with scikit-learn and you
might be more familiar with losses than
with scores in general even though this
is just a matter of choice of sign any
questions about this if there's no
questions I'm going to proceed very
quickly with this night full of formulae
that is meant as a cheat sheet it will
be on the video and you can look it up
it is also in a comparable form and
decided papers so this will be a side of
examples which I'm not going to go
through in detail just for your
convenience to look at what commonly
used losses are okay this is one
question okay so here's the cheat sheet
you might have seen the cross entropy
loss this may be the most popular loss
that you use in fitting probabilistic
neural networks there's others there's
some poor predictive intervals for
regression you can do similar things
there's a ranked probability to loss so
skipping that it's on the video right
you can get it from the video so now I'm
going to talk about bad ideas so the
things that I have seen in practical in
the practical settings and which are not
good things to do so and it's not
obvious it's not at all obvious why
these are bad things to do so one way
that seems reasonable is well if you
have a predictive interval and it says
this is 95% this is 50% just check
whether this number with the number that
you observe in practice how often the
value is in this interval is actually 95
now that seems reasonable but the
problem is the implication is only one
way and so if the prediction is perfect
then of course 95% of the observations
will have been in 95% interval but the
reverse is not true because if you think
carefully the label distribution itself
will have that property and that doesn't
give us any information about the
features second bad idea
well you're predicting a distribution
selects a sample from it and stick it in
a point prediction loss just compute the
mean square error average over samples
from the distribution maybe it's a
sample from the predictive posterior you
stick it in the O and it should be an
average but this is also bad so no
matter how you scale it so this is also
a bad idea but also for a very subtle
reason and the reason is Jensen's
inequality because this kind of
evaluation favors point prediction right
so the if you measure prediction this
way then predicting the mean of the
sample it will always be better than
averaging over this because of convexity
of the loss right Jensen's inequality
look at that but it's a bad idea also
bad idea number 3 3 believe that all
uncertainty predictions are correct and
it's obvious why this idea is bad by now
I hope finally best modeling and testing
practice so essentially for estimating
the goodness of the model same
principles as a non probabilistic
supervised learning applies to trained
test plate observing performance on the
test set is say is still a valid
principle still you don't want to tune
on the test set it's difficult to
enforce if you have off shells Bayesian
models so you want to be careful or if
you use frequentist models if it's more
hygienic if used Ritz or CV to
encapsulate the model and don't do
anything manual about the test and
validation split and leave it to Kritzer
cv say as in scikit-learn of course
computing meaningful confidence
intervals for the performances and
choosing meaningful baselines is also
important so just like just like in a
non probabilistic setting the of course
the question is what are these
meaningful baselines so the uninformed
baseline or uninformed kind of baselines
are those that always predict the same
kind of outcome here to distribution so
the manal model will be the best such
uninformed baseline for classification
you might have heard about it that's
just always predicting the same thing
which is the class frequencies on the
training set which estimates the long
term the long-term best uninformed
distribution for regression it is more
complex there you have to do density
estimation so in a sense you need to use
the best density estimator for the label
distribution ignoring all the features
then you have another thing which is non
probabilistic baselines which is always
use the same shape of distribution use
the scale parameter determined from the
label distribution alone and vary the
mean and I say use one method say to
predict the mean and the rest is
constant so scale parameter you might
need to estimate that from the from the
data distribution right so that's it
back to the package itself so we'll need
maybe two or three more minutes so I
said the features should now be more
clear by what I have explained so model
construction included composites such as
one method predicts the mean the other
one predicts the variance and the
unified interface which in this case
means it needs to predict distributions
and both in cooling and success control
this probabilistic losses appear so grid
search CV needs to evaluate models by
the predictions on internally but that
can be done because of duck typing in
Python and as well for evaluation you
want to use this proper scoring rules
the proper losses so talking just very
briefly so I'm not going to have time
for the two Peter notebook but you have
their tutorials on the SK Pro webpage
and I'm going to show you that after the
event so the notebook
made for illustration now one of the
ideas is to have a distribution
interface for the return object so
predict the result of predict acts as a
distribution of which you can call PDF
and CDF methods and that allows you to
evaluate these probabilistic losses you
have a composition interface for some of
the simpler strategies one supervised
method directly taken from s killer and
say predicts the mean the other one
predicts the scale parameter and you can
also complicate that with other
parameters you have model Diagnostics
with the probabilistic so actual label
predicted label with variance drawn in
and the yellow bars these are the losses
you can see if an individual pretty if
an individual prediction has a high loss
that's probably a outlier pair and
benchmarking so it's a little bit buggy
the benchmarking feature I said we're
still looking for and you main developer
and contributors furthermore so there's
actually other projects happening at the
touring which I wanted to mention of
which escape row in which escape row
might have an important part so
currently I'm spending most time in the
tool box area on a package that is meant
to deal with time series so supervised
learning with time series forecasting
forecasting when examples are available
event modeling so it has a relatively
large vision and currently we're trying
to ramp up people power on that one now
if you do as things like time to event
modeling or time series modeling we're
interested in modeling details you want
to have some probabilistic interface so
even even if the development of SK pro
is tolling we might be reusing part of
the probabilistic prediction interface
and if you're interested to be involved
in any of these just let me know or
apply on the webpage take-home messages
first probabilistic predictions so what
what does that mean the algorithm
produces an interval for regression or
fuel distribution so one should consider
one could consider the probabilistic
classifiers as well
algorithms that return probability must
functions so it's not so awful for
regression that's why the SK provision I
think is quite helpful so it's part
vision part an existing thing composite
workflows that are frequentist so just
take sq learn different sq learn
estimators for different parts of
predicting a semi parametric or a
parametric distribution that might also
already do the job and building
algorithms composites and pipelines just
as an SQL urn I think is the way to go
up to fully fully optimizable learning
networks or you will network like a
black box ones which is currently a bit
in the future seconds an algorithm tells
you something about its uncertainty no
reason to believe it that means checking
so frequently is Bayesian or other still
want to check it and the way to do it is
so one way to do it is wire
strictly proper losses and last but not
least we're always looking for competent
data scientists so there are a number of
toolbox projects in the PI data
ecosystem some julia projects as well so
the I think the only currently in
development julia machine learning
toolbox is at the touring there's a
number of Python projects which deal
with time series related tasks
probabilistic tasks benchmarking so you
may want to get involved in those help
building the next generation of toolbox
frameworks where they're currently
lacking so if you're available say
full-time or part-time starting June or
July for cutting-edge Emily I research
are interested to put your excellent
programming skills to use while learning
on ml and I getting involved in
applications and broadening your skill
sets talk to me in the breaks in an
email or apply via the touring website
so there are certain fast-track
processes affiliated with projects of
course there would be a proper
application and review process as well
but if you're specifically interested in
the Python projects if you are if you
have a software development background
and a little bit of mlx
Ariane's then it is not an opportunity
to contribute but also an opportunity to
learn and we have coffee that flows from
taps
[Applause]
thank you very much friends for that
talk we have time for one quick question
and when I say question just to remind
everyone that's not a statement that's
simply a question said in under one
breath that hand went up first there's a
microphone just in front of you it
should be a mic there and press the
button to talk on the mic and I think
that'd work
yes I can hear you
so computation of the complexity in
general do you repeat the question
please I'm not sure it came out between
very quick and very long depending on
whether you as an explicit method
stochastic gradient descent or a number
of varieties of Bayesian inference nice
so I think that's the question we need
to follow up during the break or
possibly friends are you joining us in
deeper but the energies the interface
we're not we're not actually implemented
method so we interface in PI MC 3 and it
is as long as pi MC 3 takes if you if
you use it it is as long as scikit-learn
takes if you call if you get linear
regression from scikit-learn and put a
gosh model around that is that a more
helpful version of this answer just
hopefully it's gonna be I think so let's
thank front
[Applause]